I got to get better at this plant slap
my name is Andrew you might recognize me
from the show worth it where I eat foods
at different price points with my pals
Stephen and Adam today I'm going to be
recreating one of my favorite dishes I
ever had on worth it
fancy ranch and tofu nuggets wait a
second Andrew you never ate nuggets and
ranch on worth it that's partially true
so in the double cheeseburger episode we
go to a place called burger Lords which
does a lot of vegan and vegetarian
interpretations of classic fast-food
dishes in particular they have these
amazing tofu nuggets and vegan fancy
ranch that's what they call it it's
actually called fancy ranch I think it's
pretty spectacular oftentimes on the
show we'll eat foods that don't make it
in the final cut of the video great
opportunity to show you some previously
unaired footage oh that's so good you
think of a meatless version of a chicken
nugget it's not obvious where it's
getting its deliciousness from I think
that these recipes explore something
that I'm really interested in which is
the fundamentals of why something tastes
good polish nuggets are a little weird
there are a weird food when you think
about it also ranch
what is ranch char device just went into
my mouth the startling so to start I'm
gonna call Fred from burger Lords to get
a little bit more information about
these recipes hey Fred how's it going
good how are you pretty good last time
I'm worth it we were trying to double
cheeseburgers but we also had these
incredible tofu nuggets as well as this
this ranch its ranch dressing right yes
yeah its ranch dressing a lot of what we
do is about no nostalgia so recreating
familiar food and the things that we
make from scratch like our recipes how
do you achieve a really delicious nugget
um I think the most important part is
for the Nugget skin I guess to call it I
mean it's not skin like been nugget
batter yeah it's super crunchy flavorful
it's like cavernous and has all of the
little cracks in it and then the tofu is
that it the tofu is actually seasoned
really well so we break it down and
process it it has a dried mushroom
for umami flavor and then it actually
has something called chicken spice mu
it's like a salt blend but there's no
chicken and it just it says chicken
sighs I've checked you know multiple
times it that kind of helps push it over
the top you're getting flavor through
the whole thing I look forward to making
these nuggets awesome yeah and let me
know if you need any help or anything
just like text me or email me first
stage is going to be assembling the tofu
into nugget shape with some flavoring
ingredients the first ingredient we're
gonna deal with is actually one that I
already have dried shiitake mushrooms
which I personally use in things like
soups this is what we're dealing with
here these may in fact be porcini
mushrooms I'm not sure I we're gonna
take these mushrooms and actually grind
them up into a powder so it can flavor
the entire nugget I have created like a
mushroom sawdust
we need to crumble the tofu this is a
really annoying packaging there's a lot
of liquid here okay
here we have our tofu look at that do I
like tofu I do
unfortunately my introduction to tofu
was with horley executed health food and
it wasn't until I had a Chinese dishes
like Mapo tofu that I came to really
love it so my instruction was to use
firm tofu I'm gonna break it apart into
the texture of ricotta cheese I will add
our mushroom dust the next ingredient is
chicken seasoned a blend of seasonings
salt garlic paprika turmeric sugar onion
white pepper cumin black pepper
you also have monosodium glutamate MSG
which has gotten a bad rap in the past
for being like this artificial thing
that could get you sick those myths have
been debunked it's really no worse for
you than regular table salt and in fact
it's a thing that naturally occurs in a
lot of foods high in umami like Parmesan
cheese tomatoes fermented foods seaweed
it does have this flavor combination
that I associate with chicken
oh you know what it tastes like chicken
flavored instant ramen plus a nacho
cheese Dorito I mean it definitely looks
like Dorito dust okay and then the
recipe also calls for a little bit more
salt and black pepper okay it's funny I
do really associate this smell with
chicken it's kind of like the pumpkin
spice fallacy where people think that
pumpkin spice stuff has pumpkin in it or
that that flavor is pumpkin but really
it's the spices that flavor pumpkin and
not pumpkin flavor I'm also gonna add
more tofu cuz I didn't do the directions
right this is the good stuff okay cut
this whole part out oh okay it's not my
favorite sensation it's so wet this is
supposed to be a half inch there's
really no other binding agent here
alright oh okay I need a text fret to
make sure that this is okay I just sex
it Fred he said this is it okay so these
are supposed to be about half an inch
thick remind myself of what that is this
is too thick man I love any food that is
in the heika homogeneous squishy mixture
and put it into a shape category like
making meatballs okay so these nuggets
now I have to go in the freezer for 24
hours before they can be breaded see you
tomorrow I may actually have to
rearrange some stuff in my freezer
okay so we're breading the Nuggets the
first thing we're gonna do is make a
vegan buttermilk to dip the Nuggets in
before dredging them in flour an energy
egg replacer when I was looking for this
in the store is looking for a liquid did
not expect to have it be a powder this
contains stuff like potato starch
tapioca which is going to be doing some
of the thickening action required to
make this like a buttermilk absolutely
zero odor off of that 100% zero
something actually Adam told me is that
I
I smell things too much like it's like a
habit of mine okay chef burrito makes a
second appearance
I made salmon for dinner last night
brillo chef burrito on the crispy skin
amazing soy milk I was supposed to shake
this main liquid component of this
buttermilk is soy milk
I usually don't buy because I don't
think it's particularly tasty however we
went to Taiwan for worth it we had that
soy milk
the first dumpling restaurant Wow big
time web it's similar satisfaction to
having a milkshake truly a taste of this
it's not the same what do we got now a
little Dijon and you I'm just gonna
eyeball it a couple tablespoons of
mustard boom
mustard is really pretty freakin good I
love mustard Wow well these are two
things I never thought I'd be whisking
together distilled vinegar got it
I'm looking at dairy and I'm smelling
vinegar haven't flashback to the pie
episode ooh you know the smell is not
pleasant currently okay liquids going
into the dry shall I taste
not very pleasant now also it curse me
that I've never tasted regular
buttermilk not really sure what my point
of reference is supposed to be next up
we're gonna be making a flour dredge to
bread the Nuggets in wipe the dust out
of this it's clean everything's very
clean in my house
pepper milled by hands Saul cayenne
pepper and the last thing here is old
bay old bay is like this iconic American
seafood seasoning its ingredients are
celery salt and paprika salt and pepper
basically that that's entirely yet I
think I just realized for the first time
that will they just smells like celery
really makes me feel like I'm doing some
kind of like witchcraft you know the
last instruction is to add a little bit
of this buttermilk to this flour so
basically just the the goal here is to
make clumps in the flour so that those
clumps can then stick to the outside of
the nugget giving it more texture this
is very satisfying this has a very
similar satisfaction to like playing in
mud as a little kid time to get the
frozen nuggets
Wow they look extremely unappetizing
that's what they look like look at that
I'm like oatmeal cookies right pretty
weird dunk
mmm and then this goes here there you go
that's a frickin nugget I mean you you
deep-fry that how did that not taste
good oh right they will freeze for
another 24 hours so we're making burger
Lords vegan ranch which they call fancy
ranch what are the key flavor components
of ranch like why does it taste so good
it's number one that herbs Dale arts the
tarragon and just a mix of that with the
onion and garlic tastes like a ranch
like you I like imagine myself on a
bottle of Hidden Valley like it is that
feeling you know and when you have the
mayonnaise what really distinguishes it
from regular mayonnaise is that regular
mayonnaise is oil and eggs emulsified
together and this is primarily oil than
other things to stabilize its emulsion
like soy protein okay and the rest of
this is pretty straightforward there's
garlic powder onion powder there's a
little bit of plain salt white vinegar
mixing this up now doesn't that look
good and then lastly there's a bunch of
herbs first we have tarragon uh-huh okay
here's all you need to know about
tarragon tastes like the licorice all
right here we go
Aragon next we're gonna do 8 grams of
dill dill is one of my favorite herbs
still shows up in a lot of Ukrainian
cuisine which is the cuisine of my
family dill is kind of unlike any of the
other herbs we won't do the super thick
parts of the stem although those are
perfectly edible how do you describe
dill if grass was delicious it's the one
that is most classically associated with
the flavor of ranch last but not least
parsley herbs might be my favorite
category of food is that a dumb thing to
say okay this is our ranch ooh
it's funny it just immediately started
smelling like what I associate ranch to
be Wow fancy ranch it's very fresh
tasting I'm ready to start deep frying
I've got my Dutch oven here about half
way full of oil this is what they look
like thick fairly nervous for this this
is the documentation of my apartment
burning down please show it to no one
here goes nothing
seems okay so far see what that looks
like oh yeah
we need to get nuggety already oh yeah
you see that camera to either giant
nuggets
the first time appreciated just our
giant peas and nuggets really are okay
at this precise moment I'm convinced
that you really want to excellently made
tofu nugget should go to burger Lords
frying at home is very troublesome oh
yeah now it's getting really goal
I think this one looks particularly good
that don't like nuggets Adam you're
about to receive a text message from me
I bet your response will just be a
single exclamation mark frying foods is
one of these things where you think it's
done or you should really just wait
another 30 or 40 seconds and then you're
like oh there there it's done okay we've
done frying it's time to try the Nuggets
this in the shot my nuggets
these suckers I think these look pretty
close okay
nugget into ranch yes
look at that nugget huh they're huge
[Music]
hmm Wow
oh those are good I'm thrilled with how
these came out in my opinion they're far
superior to regular chicken nuggets
because the inside is a much softer
texture so you have this way bigger
contrast between the outside and the
filling inside Adam always says that
inside is like the texture of scrambled
egg I kind of have to agree I'm going to
fry up some fresh ones for Adam drive
them over to him and see what he thinks
jeez these nuggets are huge yeah is it
hard that Burger Lord's ones pretty big
they're big but these are like I don't
know if you can even call these nugget
[Music]
so what else is going on at Burger
Lord's right now with quarantine and
trying to get the restaurant back in a
rhythm we were able to do a few special
project we're making meals for senior
citizens we partnered with shelter and
Skid Row to provide meals for homeless
just recently we partnered with some
friends to do a fundraiser burger for
n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund it's
giving us some time to reflect and be
able to you know integrate a more
charitable aspect to the restaurant
[Music]